欢迎收看最佛心幽默的财经节目
理财达人秀
我是李兆华
好股市又开始播放起了
登登登登
大家都在等
今天的成交量又稍微萎缩了
上市量只剩下6000亿左右
在等什么呢
当然明天台指期的结算
礼拜四的联准会利率决策会议
可是大家也不没要说
这些事情不是上个礼拜就已经知道了吗
当然还加入了一个就是AI末日论
很担心AI在高速的发展下
会对人类的权益有所伤害
但真的是如此吗
昨天我们有特别独家跟大家分享
这比较像是资本市场的阴谋
不过在观望的时候
其实机会是越浮现越多
为什么大家真的要思考一下
因为现在盘面上的这些利空
不管是油价比较高
可能要升息
AI可能降规降速
都是已经听过的利空
所以它的杀伤力没有这么强
只是市场上变得比较闷
比较闷的话就要听听看
我们来宾的想法了
因为在盘面底下暗潮汹涌
故事很多就等点那一把火
点了之后后面的利多会不断喷出
来欢迎他们
第一位是AI达人蔡明翰
好看到明翰哥
我们的信心就来了
他要特別提醒大家
等一下會把剛剛提到的利空
一一解讀
告訴大家
這些事情都不是新鮮事
尤其這幾天
討論非常熱烈的
AI降貴降速
在今天的盤面上
是很影響到科技股的
可是他絕對不是什麼新的故事
以前就發生過了
而且大廠們的反應是什麼
川普打電話給黃仁勳
在一個Live的Podcast
說沒有AI末日
所以等一下告訴你
利空拿掉之后
营收好的股价有回档的
率先布局的第一梯次
是哪一些名和独家奖咯
好第二位是古琪双分析师
纪委名小明同学
今天看到建策跌停板
怎么样鬼故事又来了
之前两片变一片
现在说三片变两片
但今天的跌停板没有所死
所有的散热股都有点受到影响
会不会重演之前散热股的问题呢
小明同学今天也有独家的解释
但看到台大电稍微翻起来咯
所以契机就在这里面
另外也提到资本支出的前进脚步
丝毫没有减缓的情况下
封测股虽然今天表现也不是很理想
但快了
第四季的封测股业绩都会全面往上
现在是布局好时间
第三位是当冲波弹双刀流高献荣
献荣也要讲现在盘面上强的是谁呢
子安股嘛
因为黄仁轩一讲到资安
Enthorpic也讲到资安
其实美国的资安大厂
股价都在创历史新高
那我们这两天大家会担心
会不会是一日行情呢
因为他们以前的成交量比较冷
所以信荣说大户已经进驻了
而且今天也帮我们检验
有一些最近集谍的
像所谓的精彩啊
大力光啊
友达啊
大家关心的
大户都偷偷在买
还有今天信荣带来了
第三季预估会创新高的好公司
投信也在狂买
到底他们看到什么商机
等一下告诉您
首先有请明翰
今天非常非常需要你
因为量缩下来了
大家盘面上有很多很多的利空
担心升息
担心油价
担心所谓的AI末日
如果我觉得最猛的是
川普居然在一个节目里面
对不对
黄仁勋在上Podcast
他就打电话给他
那今天是明翰来上我的Podcast
看看谁会打电话给你
营收强股价低的
你觉得就是第一提次要布局
对应该这样讲
現在市場確實亮說
結論就是大家有點看不懂
方向不明確
也不是說到底是多還是空
各有論點
所以導致多空都沒辦法
目前正在震盪
觀望這些到底
這些變數會長怎樣
那比較重要的就是
大家現在在講AI大佬
要喊著要放慢腳步
對 但我常常講川普聚才 煞車我覺得這是非常非常重要的關鍵因為畢竟決定權在他應該說這些人他是一個賤言他是認為應該這麼做
可是他不願意
那其中他就提到四個論點
第一個就是現在正在領先
那如果他減速等於是讓出優勢
他就在講他們對中國的關係
就是說他們現在是贏的
他不可能現在放慢腳步
第二他覺得這個末日說
有點被過度渲染了
川普真的是怕跑出中國
所以我常常講的
他才是最重要
當然他在這個Podcast的中間
這個所謂馬上call in
還開call in
對 我是當然覺得
也許有一點點
可能本來就有這個
說好的一個狀況
Faigun
對 有一點這個概念
但是確實非常具有題材性
他會擴大大家的這個
等於說大家知道
這件事情的這個滲透率
其實對整個AI的部分反而是真相
其實馬斯克在2023年3月
其實就有發出一樣的警訊
當時他有發出公開信
提到要暫緩
這次是暫緩
應該說這次希望腳步慢下來
當時希望完全暫停6個月
對 當時是說
希望整個AI的進展
先暫停6個月
因為當時是TradeGTV釋出來
然後他覺得當時
跨越的速度太快
他說只要比這個
更先進的系統
暫停訓練
他現在的說法是
你訓練沒關係
但是你要上市的時候
我們先檢查一下安全性
那時候講得更誇張
是希望大家都先不要訓練
而且這個議題
全球有三萬人去連署
認為他講的內容是贊成的
但是憑良心講
這是當時公開信說的時間點
你看我們都已經有點忘記這件事
大家根本就不太理他
這個股市不斷漲
當然我要先講一個重點
因為當時是在二三年
剛剛起漲AI正出來的時候
因為當時位階低
所以說完完全不理它
持續往上噴
現在位階高
稍有一點點的疑慮就會震盪
我覺得是非常合理
可是就我個人而言
我個人覺得這個真是兩天題材
就是最後抵不過那個所謂聯準會
很快大家就會忘了這件事情
當然剛剛提到
油價往上準備升息
美債殖利率最近來講
也是大幅走高
看到兩年期 十年期 三十年期
尤其是十年期都已經突破5%
對 那尤其我們之前
也跟大家分享
三十年期領先創高
那時候兩年期是不太動
我們那時候跟大家講
短線不動這代表著
大家不認為那麼快
會去做升息的動作
只是覺得長期有壓力
就因為最近剛剛提到油價上升
所以升息機率大幅走高
所以這幾天連兩年期都噴出去
所以看起來這個高殖利率
當然應該說美債殖利率大幅走高
大家多少會有點擔憂
可是我要講的概念
就是真正的壓力來源
一定是最後經濟出了問題
股市才會大跌
而且股市大跌
你一定會看到資金賣的股
會跑到公債去
所以公債殖利率會走低
所以長期間我就講了
之前金融風暴的時間點
紅色是股市
藍色是公債殖利率
永遠都是走銅向
所以我就覺得很納悶
那個公債殖利率往下是利空
往上也是利空
這個一聽就知道不太合理
所以其實過往經驗
你只要看到股市真的大跌
理論上公債殖利率是往下的
所以往上會導致
短時間的市場信心稍微有動搖
但絕對不會是
因為公債殖利率創高
導致股市後來呈現長期的空頭
我就要跟大家講
這概念可能要稍微去扭轉一下
好 要去釐清一下
公債殖利率往下
還是真正大風險
大家很害怕的時候
對 往上的話
現在是反映可能通膨要升息
是 另外就是這樣
升息其實也更不用擔心
有些我剛剛提到
現在九成的機率都要升息
代表這個禮拜升息就是如玉期所以股市絕對不會因為如玉期而崩盤絕對不可能那其中我永遠講真正升息會導致股市下跌
就是2022年的時候
他一樣從0到0.25開始升息
第一次他升了1碼
第二次升2碼
第三次之後連續4次都升3碼
結論來講就是真的
最重要的是速度
並不是升息
升息其實對股市
緩步的升息股市仍然持續往上
但是他當時的狀況是
連續四次都升息三馬
而且在這個情況下
一路從0到5.25
所以結論就是
升息其實也沒什麼好害怕的
尤其這一次幾乎都已經
市場都有所預期
最後我自己的觀點
用這個表可能會比較理解
用三種情境
對 如果這個禮拜
我們這個情境全部都是升息了
因為我個人覺得九成
我們就以升息的交流
對 升息了
但是呢 它的中性偏割
中性偏割應該說
要看到的是聯準會的態度
聯準會態度看兩個東西
一個是點證圖
一個是會後的
這個主席的說法
如果中性偏割
中性偏割是什麼
就是未來的動向
它會參考經濟數據
就是它不講未來會怎樣
就是未來如果真的通膨
很嚴重 我就升
如果掉下來我就不升
類似這種概念
股市來講應該就會
利空出金
可是我希望能夠利空出境
有一個條件
就是這幾天股市不要反彈
就是不要漲 壓在這裡
對 壓在這裡
跌不跌不重要
但不要在出來之前就反彈
我覺得對股市是比較好的
那只要
只要它偏中性不講未來
股市就會漲
第二種情境就是偏陰了
我剛剛提到
從點證圖跟它的說法
都可以告訴你
今年這一次
絕對不是只有一次升行
可能年底還有
對 年底還有
甚至有可能三次
因為它9月 10月 12月
搞不好每一次都升一嘛
所以代表著還會持續升息
那這個結論來講就會
一到兩天會有壓力
但絕對不會是長期趨勢
因為我們前段就提到
長期的這個緩步升息
對股市其實不會有明顯的壓力
但是第三種情境
就是回到2022年
好 我們再來就講
那講到說那奇怪
這台積電今天雖然是撐盤要腳
可是你可以看到
它趨勢一直以來
就沒有太強的一個表現
他今天不跌中小型股好慘喔
對 他會
今天來講真的是靠他撐盤
但是我會常常講
就是現在上不去的原因
其實是因為台股的位階
真的就是比較高
因為我們對比費半
我們的位階就是高
所以我常常講費半
你不如乾脆看台積電跟ADR就知道
你可以看到高點跟對高點
後續壓回
其實台股跌勢沒有比較小
但是很快就反彈到
幾乎再回到快到起跌點
可是現在的ADR距離高點
其實還超過一成以上
所以明顯的有這個不同的差距
另外這兩張圖的位階不同
就會引發這溢價差的變化
所謂的溢價差
結論而言就是長期ADR一定比這邊貴
所以你把這個換算成
美金400多元換算成台幣
然後再除以5回到這個價格
這個中間的差距
只要越高
代表著就是多頭的一個趨勢
現在呢這一加差一直說減到
剩不到15%
過往經驗確實會
壓抑著這個股價表現
所以我剛剛講未來的
要的是他想辦法去突破
回到這個突破之前的壓力區
那台股才有機會往上
記得未來一件事
如果他還在這裡震盪
但台積電想辦法去突破這
千萬不要買
這個簡單來講
就台如果自己
這個ADR不去突破
這裡先去突破
千萬不要買 這一定會壓回的
好 我們等ADR表態
是一個很重要的事情
就是結論來講
就是要讓這個溢價差拉開了
才代表著會有多頭的一個趨勢
回到這個台積電壓抑
台積電營收創力史新高
沒辦法有效的表現
當然最近營收好的個股
其實今天來講
也都有一定的壓力
台積電不寂寞
這邊都是營收創高但壓力看起來現在比較大的其實比較重要的關鍵點應該說最近因為股市震盪所以很多人其實也不太看這個基本面還會看現行
但是確實我們列出來個股
這些個股就是八月營收
創立歷史新高
而且今年這個
我們看到營收年增長
還有累積的
還包含今年的獲利
其實都是
簡單來你用各樣條件塞
人家都是資優生
都是前段班
對 可是今天股價是跌的
所以我覺得記得一件事
現在震盪的時間點
反而是尋找這些
本來就是基本面好
最近拉回反而是佈局的機會
可是這檔其實他還好
他有創歷史新高
我們今天來講
找到的個股
是相對比較強勁一點的個股
那當然我剛剛講的不同的故事
這種就比較屬於
喜歡短線操作的
你可以盡量選擇比較強勢的
我們前段看這麼多個股
裡面的這個個股反而弱的買
我覺得也沒有問題
弱的代表什麼
就是你需要一點時間
它不可能V型反彈
但是你只要時間放長
它的空間會比較大
強勢的個股代表著
你很快就有機會獲利
但是因為它位階高
所以獲利的空間
自然就會受到壓縮
沒有絕對的好與壞
那因為營收非常強勢
昨天試圖創高
今天就被壓回
所以我覺得這個短線來講
它這個趨勢來講
應該都還有機會再持續往上
那帶動不同的個股
一樣IP
我們講IP股
對 相對來講呢
市新就弱勢很多
怎麼了 這發生什麼事
這營收明明就好到爆啊
對 我們先講一下故事
看一下這是24年營收
這25年營收
所以前一段時間很弱是應該的
因為之前掉單
所以它的營收掉是很合理
今年上半年還在震盪
甚至比前兩年更低
那時候就在講
Amazon訂單快進來了
之前那時候市場的預期
都會落在三四月就會進來
稍微有點延遲
但還不錯 後續就噴出了
可是為什麼這個月公佈之後會掉
其實很簡單
就是公司之前的法說會
很多的場合
他沒有講得很明
但是法人從他的言語之間
大家都預期
可能應該有機會突破100
結果出來的數字
有一點點不如預期
還要比這個數字更好就對了
因為你可以看到它的斜率
在這個月確實有一點點的比
等於說跟之前的斜率稍微有不同
所以可以看得出來
結果是有點不如預期
大家都原本預期會過100這條軸線
但是憑良心講
因為它的
它接到了Amazon的這個單是一個配件
所以代表著
它不會到這裡就是頂一點
所以我個人覺得在這裡壓回
倒不用過度緊張
不要 一樣問題
我常常講多看數字
不要永遠都看線型
人家的營收其實長這樣
只是這個月大家有點點
等於說過度樂觀
出來沒有到達那麼樂觀的情況下
反而壓回
但我覺得未來他不會到
簡單來講這個營收不會是高點
未來還有機會再往上
所以我覺得也不用緊張
因為今天ASIC相關的IP股
都是比較壓抑的
就是被那個降規降速
可能有點影響到了
應該說今天IP都弱
但是剛好世新是在
公布營收就已經轉弱
所以導致他今天看起來
又特別弱勢
會有這個雙重的壓抑的效果
那我們講到金居
他就算是相對比較穩健
所以我們今天來講也算是
他也算是盡量看能不能短線
就盡快轉強
因為他的走勢
之前相對樣弱勢的時間很長
他等於說比市場
比較容易發現打底之後
開始轉強
所以我覺得短時間一樣
就是營收創歷史新高
那今天來講
股價有出現比較明顯的壓回
趋勢還是不變
所以近期反而壓回
就因為AI放慢的言論
或者是這個禮拜
有可能因為
這FOMC升息的一個情況下
如果壓回
我覺得這裡都還是可以做
承接的動作
好 如果營收很好
而股價大幅回檔
你是最喜歡的啦
是 沒錯
但是現階段
台股的基本面已經好成這樣
所以很難看到那種劇烈的回檔
因此只要他在這邊盤整
而營收持續保持良好的
你都覺得是一個首選
是
好 準備非常謝謝明翰
謝謝